[Music]
straight ahead on law on crime daily
a fugitive on the run the national
manhunt for brian laundry but no charges
yet in the death of gabby petito the the
odds are the overwhelming odds are that
she was killed by someone she knows plus
there's no evidence the jury heads to
deliberation in the federal case against
r kelly then trial begins for the
mennonite murder this defendant mark
gooch
kidnapped and murdered sasha krauss we
bring you up to speed on the case of a
former u.s airman accused of killing a
young teacher and later derek chauvin
pushing back on his murder conviction in
the death of george floyd how the ex-cop
requests an appeal to his conviction
long crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome to lawn prime daily i'm simon
choudry in for brian buckmeyer along
with terry austin now we begin with a
nationwide manhunt brian laundry is
officially a wanted man an arrest
warrant is now out for laundry after a
grand jury indicted him in connection to
the death of gabby petito angenette levy
is here with the details of the charge
laundry faces
brian laundry faces one federal charge
of unauthorized use of access devices
specifically the fbi says that laundry
used gabby potito's debit card and pin
the indictment says laundry used the
capital one debit card from august 30th
to september first and obtained things
of value of one thousand dollars or more
that would have been three days after a
family's gopro recorded what appeared to
be gabby potito's van in the spread
creek dispersed camping area of the
bridger teton national forest potito's
body was found in that area on sunday
the coroner said petito's death is a
homicide and the fbi says laundry is a
person of interest forensic death
investigator joseph scott morgan spoke
about the arrest warrant
when the feds issued this warrant
was that they set in motion to put him
in direct sights of the feds as a
fugitive and now they've unleashed the
power of the u.s marshals service
and u.s marshal service specializes in
hunting people and tracking them down
and bringing them in and that's what's
going to happen now fbi special agent in
charge michael schneider issued a
statement saying while this arrest
warrant allows law enforcement to arrest
mr laundry the fbi and our partners
across the country continue to
investigate the facts and circumstances
of ms potato's homicide we urge
individuals with knowledge of mr
laundry's role in this matter or his
current whereabouts to contact the fbi
brian laundry's attorney issued a
statement saying it's his understanding
that this charge is related to events
that occurred after gabby petito's death
and not her actual demise steve
bertolino went on to say that the charge
in the allegations contained in it will
be addressed in the proper forum after
the fbi locates brian laundry for law
and crime daily i'm ian jeannette levy
all right thanks angenet for that report
meantime authorities they continue the
manhunt for laundry in a florida reserve
he was last seen tuesday now the search
began for him last friday reports now
say he left his family home without his
cell phone or wallet his parents say
they're concerned he may hurt himself
all this comes after an ill-fated
cross-country road trip potido was last
seen alive near grand teton national
park in wyoming laundry returned to his
family's home in florida without petito
driving her van a funeral is scheduled
for petito near her family home in new
york on sunday
let's bring in co-host terry austin and
legal analyst dina dahl now dina i want
to start with you if brian laundry is
found can we expect federal charges
being that gabby petito's body was found
in a national park which is federal land
it is true that if a murder is committed
on federal land then federal charges are
brought we don't know yet though if she
was actually killed in the national park
or if it was just her body was disposed
there so we will you know as they do
more of the investigation they have
ruled it the coroner's ruled it a
homicide but they haven't yet revealed
you know where maybe she was killed
so that's a little bit unclear still as
we know the federal you know they
already have a federal arrest warrant
for him so it's possible if he is caught
that there may be a federal murder
charge brought for him also
and terry social media is circulating a
theory that someone can commit murder in
the zone of death and not be prosecuted
is that true and explain what this is
absolutely not true this zone of death
means that
under the sixth amendment frankly you
have the right to be prosecuted for
criminal charges in the same state and
district apparently the federal district
is in wyoming but it's in the state of
idaho where this zone is but as dina
just mentioned under federal law under
title 18 usc
you can
basically bring a federal charge against
anyone because it occurs on federal
property and this is yellowstone it's
federal property there's no question you
cannot get away with murder anywhere in
the united states usually it's going to
be by the state in this case it would be
by the federal government
yeah any for even more coverage on the
gabby petito case of course everyone is
paying attention to this listen to the
law and crime podcast cocktails and
cocktails this week host sergeant shawn
sticks-larkin sits down with retired
homicide detective danny smith who gives
us his take on brian laundry's
involvement in her death
but the point is everything is pointing
toward this boyfriend
and as an investigator you always want
to stay in the middle of the road you
don't want to come to conclusions but
you do want to say well
i used to say it like this it's not that
i'm investigating him as a suspect but i
have to exclude him as a suspect because
just from the circumstances he is going
to be on a list of people that i'm going
to consider a suspect and i need to
exclude him
and if you work really hard to exclude
someone who turns out to be guilty
you're really actually in he end up
building a really good case you know
and you can listen to cop tales and
cocktails on apple podcasts or wherever
podcasts can be found
well still ahead on long crime daily
opening statements and a mennonite
murder case what can we expect from
arizona versus mark gooch
but first closing arguments are over in
the federal trial of r kelly when can we
expect a verdict in the singer's trial
all this and more coming up next
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to long crime daily the
jury is out in the federal trial of r
kelly kelly faces a multitude of charges
including racketeering and sex
trafficking most of his sexual
accusations included women who were
under the age of 18 at the time
over five weeks of testimony 45
witnesses and 11 accusers spoke out
against the r b singer explaining their
experience with his alleged abuse
disturbing testimonies included how the
singer would lock girls in a room with
no food or water forced them to have sex
with him and that the singer knowingly
transmitted herpes the defense called
five witnesses most of whom were former
employees of kelly their testimonies
often contained contradictions
and as closing arguments wrapped on
friday kelly's lawyer said quote
so he became a sex symbol
where is the crime in that
do you think your closing argument was
effective
that's not for the jury to discern what
do you think the main point you want
them to walk away from that was
that's no evidence
let's bring back terry and dina terry
we're learning that the jury has
requested the testimony of jane doe
number three what do you think this
means you know sarma i think it means
they want to hear that testimony from
the beginning to the end she was a
little unusual she went to interview
kelly actually never got the interview
she said she was locked in a room that
she was starved when she finally did get
some food she felt drugged she woke up
he was standing over her she felt some
wet between her legs so she knew
something had happened she said she
didn't say anything about it because she
was afraid and he threatened her so the
jury is probably thinking she's
different from the rest she didn't go
there to be with r kelly wondering maybe
why she didn't report it but probably
trying to focus on
what that threat was and that's a very
important part of this ricoh charge
you know let's backpedal a minute dina
on thursday r kelly's defense team
compared him to martin luther king jr
and then on friday they referred to him
as a sex symbol this is unconventional
to say the least when you're wrapping
closing arguments what do you make of
this
i mean i think he went too far for sure
i imagine he turned off a lot of jury's
jurors by comparing him to martin luther
king but i think he did a better job
when he compared him to who hefner and
you know those kind of things because he
was trying to say that just because you
may not agree with the way he conducted
his life that does not make him a
criminal and that is true
uh the
the problem is is that the prosecution
has a lot of evidence toward the fact
that he also was committing crimes and
the other thing the defense attorney
said was that all the witnesses were
liars and prior bad act witnesses were
allowed in and they are allowed in in
sexual assault cases in order to bolster
the credibility of witnesses this is why
because
the only way a defense attorney can poke
holes is to say that the witnesses were
lying the more witnesses saying the same
thing it's much harder to make that
argument
all right let's switch coasts now and
head to california in the federal trial
of elizabeth holmes former theranos
employees testify saying holmes
knowingly moved forward with the
walgreens product rollout despite
performance issues on thursday the
eight-year veteran of the company
testified she quit after concerns about
the company's capabilities the
scientists said under oath that holmes
knew her blood testing product was
ill-equipped but moved forward with the
plan involving the pharmacy store anyway
holmes faces 12 counts of fraud for her
time with the now defunct theranos the
stanford dropout claimed the company
would revolutionize blood testing but
later investigations found many problems
with those tests if convicted holmes
faces up to 20 years in prison she has
pleaded not guilty and testimony will
continue next tuesday when court resumes
for the case
well we have an update for an alleged
murder that took place decades ago
almost 45 years after her death the
so-called eskatapa jane doe supposedly
the victim of serial killer has been
identified mississippi authorities
identified the woman as clara birdlong
whose skeletal remains were found on the
side of a highway in
1977. the now deceased convicted serial
killer samuel little confessed to
killing 93 women including the eskatapa
jane doe dna evidence helped
investigators uncover the victim's
identity in december of 2020 just one
month after little's death little was
known for knocking out his victims with
punches and then strangling them right
now claire birdlong's cause of death is
still unknown
well coming up on lawn crime daily derek
shovin no money and no representation
asking for an appeal on his guilty
conviction that's coming up next and
plus we have opening statements in the
trial of the former airman accused of
murdering a mennonite school teacher
we go inside the arizona courtroom next
[Music]
and welcome back to law on crime daily
witness testimony is underway in the
trial of a united states airman accused
of murdering a mennonite woman
prosecutors say 22 year mark gooch
kidnapped and murdered 27-year-old sasha
krauss back in january of 2020. now he's
pleaded not guilty to the charges of
first degree murder kidnapping and theft
kraus was last seen shopping for sunday
school supplies near her mennonite
community in new mexico about a month
later her body was found near flagstaff
arizona and at the time gooch was
stationed at luke air force base in
phoenix an autopsy revealed krause died
of blunt force trauma and a gunshot
wound to the head a crime lab reported
that the bullet taken from krauss's
skull was fired from a gun that gooch
had in his possession cell phone records
put gooch in the area at the suspected
time of the crime and a previous text
message several text messages from the
defendant showed disdain towards the
mennonite community in court on friday
the prosecution claimed gooch sought out
a mennonite woman and took great lengths
to cover up the alleged crime by hiding
a murder weapon and cleaning the car he
kidnapped her in
the defendant contacted a friend and
asked this friend to hold some personal
items for him
one of those items being a 22 caliber
rifle
unbeknownst to the friend
and then the defendant went and got his
car professionally detailed to the tune
of 220 dollars
let's check in once again with co-host
terry austin and legal analyst dina
daldina in a case like this that
presents unconventional issues in that
the victim was a mennonite woman would
that in any way affect the witnesses
called or the trial in general
i mean i think that the prosecutor will
probably explain you know what mennonite
is
because most people may not know and
there may be some sort of stereotype or
something with that it is both of
religion and also seen as an ethnic
group and also actually they're
pacifists so they might also go to
motivation here is this violent crime
allegedly committed against a mennonite
woman because he did not like
you know the church which was a pacifist
so we will probably see them um the
prosecution tie that all in you know
help educate the jurors as to you know
what that
religion is and how the religion can
play into the motive
and terry based on the prosecution's
opening statement it sounds like there
is substantial evidence against the
defendant do you agree i do agree i
think there is a ton of circumstantial
evidence there may not be any direct
evidence and the defense attorney
actually mentioned there are no
witnesses so you won't see that type of
direct evidence but they do have his
travel records as far as his phone is
concerned he's admitted frankly that he
went from glendale to farmington so
that's not really an issue we saw that
he did computer searches according to
the prosecution for the missing woman
herself he cleaned his car i think the
biggest point here though is that 22
caliber rifle that he hid with his
friend and the forensic says that it's
the same type of bullet so i think they
have him on that circumstantial evidence
all right well we have to take a quick
break but when we come back
derek chovin appeals his conviction on
his own behalf
what comes next for the former officer
who killed george floyd
[Music]
welcome back to lawn crime daily a
kentucky man charged with murder enters
an alford plea deal in connection to the
shooting of calvin q taylor the
seven-year-old victim was found dead in
his kentucky home in october of last
year neighbors reported hearing gunshots
early that morning and taylor was
pronounced dead at the scene anthony
manning and his mother lorena were near
the scene during the crime anthony
claims he didn't enter the home until
after he heard the gunshots the mother
and son are charged with murder and
first degree robbery in a hearing on
monday anthony manning entered an alford
plea deal a guilty plea where the
defendant maintains his innocence but
acknowledges there is likely enough
evidence to result in a conviction
should the case go to trial
now to minnesota derrick chauvin
appealing his conviction in the death of
george floyd the former minneapolis
police officer was charged with the
murder and manslaughter of floyd after
kneeling on his neck for over nine
minutes he was sentenced in april to
more than 20 years in prison the former
cop is now appealing the conviction on
his own behalf to the minnesota state
supreme court after his after he was
denied a public defender
the appeal cites 14 issues including the
judge's denial to sequester the jury and
change the venue of the trial after
public outrage in the minneapolis area
the 45 year old says his in his appeal
that he is out of money and without
representation and is asking the court
to put his appeal process on hold until
his denial for a public defender has
been reviewed all right so dina why
would chauvin have been denied a public
defender
so as we know the his attorney was paid
for by his police union during the trial
but once there was a conviction they no
longer would pay for a lawyer for his
appeal so he did try to request a public
defender you are only eligible for a
public defender if you can show that
both your liquid assets and your current
income are so low that you could not
afford your own attorney so the
determination was made that he could
actually afford an attorney and it was
denied this like you said he is
appealing it interestingly
the judge cahill
initially also approved a request by
chauvin
for proper status which would mean he
wouldn't have to pay any court filings
that was reversed today so there is some
you know again in that case
he must have found that he had enough
income to be able to pay these court
filings so it's unclear whether or not
chauvin will be able to prove that he is
eligible based on the finances to get a
public defender
and let's talk about the appeal terry
what do you think about the grounds of
appeal that chauvin outlined i actually
think he did a great job outlining the
different areas it was everything in the
kitchen sink and i think many of the
areas he outlined will not be successful
so prosecutorial misconduct that's not
going to succeed i don't think i think
some of the appeal grounds like jury
misconduct also will not succeed but
there were a couple of grounds there
where i thought he had a chance
sequestering the jury might have been a
big issue change of venue would not have
been a big issue whether or not they let
in that evidentiary evidence as far as
the may 2019
incident was concerned the defense
wanted the whole part of that in and
only some
some part of it was in not the entire
part so i think that might be a good
ground and then finally i think as far
as that third degree murder charge was
concerned that was a huge issue that
could be one of the grounds that he
could succeed as far as the appeal is
concerned so you think he did a good job
outlining it but you don't think the
chances of him winning his appeals is a
good chance he did a great job outlining
it but most of the grounds are not going
to succeed he has a decent chance of
winning one all right thank you so much
ladies and thank you for joining us here
on law and crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice here in
america
[Music]
you